alors j'ai une blague comment est ce
qu'on appelle la dernière lutte qu'on a
utilisé la lutte finale que je reviens
après l'intro et salue les gens derrière
l'écran c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique moi encore je suis ravie comme
toujours de vous retrouver ici pour une
nouvelle vidéo qu'aujourd'hui on va
parler de look de colorimétrie de lutte
et de près 7 parce que ce sont des
termes que vous avez probablement déjà
beaucoup entendu et probablement vous
vous posez des questions dessus on va y
répondre dans cette vidéo
mais avant toute chose je voudrais
préciser que cette vidéo s'adresse à des
vidéastes débutant et intermédiaire
parce que dès qu'on rentre dans le monde
du cinéma
le propos qui va être tenus ici n'est
plus vraiment valable mais si vous
filmez avec un dslr ou que vous êtes un
petit vidéastes comme moi le propos il
tient la route a aucun souci mais rentre
tout de suite dans le vif du sujet on va
d'abord parler des luttes qu est-ce que
c'est une lutte si vous ne savez pas ce
que c'est et bien alain il va vous
expliquer ce que c'est qu'une lutte
alors je vais tenter de vous expliquer
rapidement ce qu'est une lutte lutte ça
veut dire look of people pour faire très
simple c'est une table de correspondance
en gros c'est pour faire correspondre
des couleurs grâce à un fichier tout
simplement
et parmi les luttes d'ailleurs on
différencie deux familles de lutte entre
guillemets on va d'abord avoir ce qu'on
appelle les luttes de conversion par
exemple là je suis en log
là j'ai utilisé une lutte de conversion
ça me permettra en fait d'amener mon
image de la rencontre as they dollar
saturé mais surtout de la changer d
espace 2 couleur espace colorimétrique
en l'occurrence pour l'exemple que vous
venez de voir il s'agissait du log vers
leurs excès de sang neuf mais il existe
aussi une deuxième façon de voir les
choses c'est les luttes de look et
celles ci vont nous servir uniquement à
donner un look est par exemple voilà et
pour aller encore plus loin je vous
conseille la vidéo qu olivier schmitt a
fait sur les luttes qui est hyper
complète qui va vraiment en profondeur
dans le concept donc je vous recommande
d'aller la voir je vous mets le lien
dans la description
alors après les luttes on va
s'intéresser au précèdent c'est pas
exactement la même chose mais c'est
hyper intéressant aussi rototo voilà
alors des prêts 7 on entend surtout
parler pour lightroom pour la retouche
photo mais ça existe aussi sur des
logiciels comme final cut première ou la
vichy est resté bien jusqu'à la fin de
la vidéo parce qu'en parlant de près 7
y a un truc qu'il faut que je vous dise
à la fin voilà reste à passer et un
preset c'est tout simplement une liste
de réglage sauvegarder pour un logiciel
données et à la différence d'une lutte
dont on va juste pouvoir modifier
l'opacité le preset on va pouvoir aller
tweak est un petit peu chaque réglage
c'est à dire que si un réglage de
contraste on pourra le régler plus ou
moins s'il ya un réglages
colorimétriques qu'on veut modifier on
pourra le modifier également d'ailleurs
dans final cut c'est hyper simple a créé
je vous montre ça tout de suite
alors ici en dessous de mes effet je
vais aller cliquer sur enregistrer le
réglages prédéfinis
je vais lui donner un nom et en avant
guingamp on a notre précède c'est hyper
simple l'avantagé c'est qu'on va pouvoir
le garder et par exemple ici ce face
caméra il n'est pas traitée avec une
lutte il est traité avec tout un tas de
réglages que je sauvegarde puisque la
configuration ici en intérieur est la
même à chaque fois ce qui nous amène à
cette question est ce que les luttes les
presets et mal est ce que il faut faire
attention est ce qu'on peut y aller les
yeux fermés c'est difficile d'être
complètement absolu sur le fait
d'utiliser des luttes ou des préceptes
qui sont pas la même chose de
privilégier l'un ou l'autre mais il ya
des choses à savoir avant de faire son
choix parce que ça ce sera le vôtre
encore auto didon et que ce sera en
fonction d'une look que vous voudrez
donner à vos images et il ya tout un tas
de cas dans lequel utiliser des luttes
ou des presets est carrément pratique
c'est carrément efficace dans le fait
d'utiliser des prêts 7 il ya un point
mois que j'aime beaucoup qui est hyper
pédagogique et qui nous permet
d'apprendre énormément c'est qu'on va
pouvoir aller voir les réglages de
quelqu'un d'autre pas forcément pour les
appliquer telle quelle à nos images mais
aussi pour comprendre comment il a pu
traiter son image et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne trouve pas dans les
luttes mais dans les précédents on va
pouvoir essayer d'analyser un petit peu
le style de tel ou tel vidéastes ou
photographes et tout ça dans le but de
créer notre propre style
moi personnellement j'ai déjà acheté pas
mal de presets au lightroom et je me
sers quasiment jamais ces préceptes
parce que ben ali ne me plaisent pas tel
quel par contre je lisais beaucoup
étudié et il ya des choses que j'ai
remarqué devant le fait pas mais tient
en utilisant tel réglage il a eu tel
résultat
c'est vachement intéressant voyons je
vais l'appliquer à mai près c'est à moi
l'autre point qui est hyper intéressant
cette fois ci c'est pour les luttes
ça va être là
rapidité d'exécution c'est à dire que si
on a un projet dans lequel on n'a
vraiment pas forcément le temps de faire
un étalonnage poussée est vraiment
vraiment travailler on va pouvoir
utiliser une lutte ça va aller vite on
va mettre un quelques des faits on va
mettre la lutte dessus ajusté 2 3 trucs
et on va avoir un résultat correct
flatteur à l'oeil selon les luttes bien
entendu on ça dépend vraiment de la
qualité de la lutte aussi mais même
chose des luttes pas forcément folle
folle on va avoir un résultat qui va
être plaisant à l'oeil de loin et si on
n'a pas d'impératif de vraiment de
qualité fine c'est clairement un énorme
gain de temps mais attention elle a
quand même de grosses précautions à
prendre avec les luttes avec les presets
est pas aussi simple que ça côté lutte
il faut se méfier de quelques petits
pièges d'abord privilégier toujours des
luttes faites par des entreprises
spécialisées dans la couleur ou alors
par des est à l'honneur évidemment on ne
peut pas faire une lutte comme ça venant
de n'importe quel écran il faut avoir un
écran au minimum étalonner et puis
surtout quelques compétences souvent
vous allez pouvoir acheter des luttes de
créateurs mais néanmoins elles auront
été talonné uniquement pour leurs
appareils photos ils n'auront pas
souvent vu d'autres cas et là c'est un
véritable problème
donc il vaut mieux faire attention et
achetés chez des professionnels et oui
parce qu'il faut aussi faire attention
au look quand on va acheter une lutte ou
utiliser une lutte qui a servi pour un
certain type de caméra il ya de grandes
chances qu'elle ne correspond pas à
notre caméra et il existe pour ça des
luttes universel donc c'est pour ça que
je vous conseille de faire attention
c'est dit lutte universelle sont en fait
est talonné sur différents profils
d'image donc différent gamin ce qui va
permettre en fait de conserver l'idée du
look peu importe votre appareil photo
il faudra néanmoins l'ajuster et la
retravailler pour qu'elle fonctionne
parfaitement donc méfiez vous de ça
parce que malheureusement il ya beaucoup
de fichiers qui circulent et qui sont de
mauvaise qualité
côté président c'est pareil a pas que
des avantages puisque les prix des tons
aussi un premier inconvénient c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas universelles et oui
comme vous l'expliqué françois en fait
les presets et sur votre logiciel
du coup si par exemple vous utilisez
adobe premiere pro vous ne pouvez pas
partager vos présente avec un gain qui
les utilisent sur final cut
également il faut penser aux mises à
jour en fonction de la mise à jour de
votre logiciel
les préceptes ne marcheront plus d'une
mise à jour al et bien sûr vous pouvez
parfois télécharger des prêts êtes assez
douteux où il vous faudra des luttes
complémentaires pour permettre
d'afficher le look sur le pré êtes et ça
c'est un vrai problème
alors bien sûr d'un point de vue créatif
c'est assez difficile de se dire qu'on
utilise la colonne
maîtrise qu'un autre cela est un
avantage est à la fois un point négatif
pensez-y n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez
également créer vos propres looks et
pour ça il faudra vous entraîner et si
tout cela est trop complexe pour vous
n'avez pas envie de franchir ce cap là
et bien vous pouvez continuer à acheter
des prêts êtes où des luttes et donc
pour finir j'aimerais vous donner juste
mon avis c'est à dire pas forcément ce
qu'il faut faire il n'y a pas de règles
particulières mais ce que moi j'ai
choisi de faire parce que ça me convient
alors j'essaye de bannir les luttes de
workflow pour une raison simple
j'ai vraiment envie de développer mon
propre style mon propre look j'ai pas
envie de plaquer un effet ou un style un
look qui n'est pas le mien
de plus en plus ça m'a beaucoup aidé au
début parce que c'est vrai que je savais
pas trop par où commencer mais quand on
va commencer à fouiller du côté de la
colorimétrie et qu'on va vraiment de
travailler un petit peu son image il
qu'on comprend surtout cause qu'est ce
qui fait quoi et comment on peut arriver
au résultat qu'on veut ben on arrive
déjà 1 à quelque chose de beaucoup plus
fin quelque chose de plus original
également puisque ce look classe ça sera
nous qui l'avons créée donc il
techniquement il ne devrait pas se
retrouver chez quelqu'un d'autre même si
beaucoup louent pouvant se ressembler et
puis elle fait que j'ai remarqué qu'à
l'export les fichiers que j'utilisais
sur lesquels j'ai appliqué des luttes
mali s'étaient pas d'aussi bonne qualité
que quand on avait utilisé des outils
dans final cut ou n'importe quel autre
type de dub éditeurs des outils de la
machine qui vraiment vont pas non plus
altéré l'image
alors forcément ça demande plus de
travail et plus de temps mais encore une
fois on peut faire des préceptes donc
ses looks j'en ai fait quelques uns sur
final cut et je me les suis enregistré
et je les ai en précède donc j'ai pas
besoin de tout refaire à chaque fois
j'ai une base même si je dois modifier
un petit peu en fonction des projets
j'ai quand même des heures et des heures
de gagner grâce aux préceptes ce qui
nous amène à ce point important pour
vous qui était déjà resté jusqu'à ce
niveau là de la vidéo j'ai sorti mon
pack de près 7 pour lightroom donc pour
le traitement des photos et ça m'a
demandé pas mal de réflexion parce que
j'étais assez mal à l'aise avec le fait
de le vendre
on en trouve beaucoup et c'est pas du
tout une mauvaise chose n'y a pas de
souci et après m'être retourner le
cerveau pour 6 de trouver une solution
pour pouvoir vous proposer ça sent
forcément le donnait en téléchargement
gratuit
mais que ce soit hyper accessible et
puis que vous puissiez les récupérer
aussi j'ai finalement trouvé grâce
multiple la solution du type vous
connaissez la plateforme qui permet de
regarder des pubs pour financer pour
faire un geste pour vos créateurs
préférés sur youtube
ils ont une partie boutique également où
l'on peut vendre des choses donc en gros
si vous cliquez sur le lien qui se
trouve dans la description pour avoir le
pack de près 7 et ben en contrepartie
d'un don de minimum 1 euro même pas le
prix d'un café vous pourrez télécharger
mon pack de cyprès cette photo pour
lightroom ici participation au niveau
sert que si vous voulez donner qu'un
euro vous donner qu'un euro si vous lui
donnez 10 euros vous pouvez donner 10
euros ou plus mais ça fait cher du coup
mais vous pouvez mettre le prix que vous
voulez à partir d'un euro donc pour moi
ça représente plus le fait de faire un
don et en contrepartie à voir le pad de
près 7
j'ai pas la sensation de vous vendre
quelque chose voilà c'était juste pour
encore une fois être transparent avec
vous et transparent avec moi aussi
auclair et droit dans mes bottes
donc voilà si si vous avez envie de
reproduire ses looks que vous avez vu
sur mon instagram et ben j'utilise
quasiment tout le temps c'est preset là
un petit peu modifié un cd précède faut
les adapter à votre à votre image à
votre caméra 1 c'est pas utiliser de
telles quelles et voilà les amis c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui c'est tout pour
cette vidéo si elle vous a plu vous
pouvez mettre le traditionnel coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo et
si vous avez téléchargé le pape de près
cet abat vous pouvez me dire dans les
commentaires ce que vous en avez pensé
vous pouvez partager cette vidéo et puis
moi je dis comme d'habitude surtout
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas bien entendu à vous
abonner à la chaîne de françois à ce qui
paraît elle est pas mal je crois faudra
vérifier mais il me semble que c'est
bien et puis s'ils voulaient passer
faire un petit tour sur ma chaîne
n'hésitez pas et je souhaite bonne
chance dans la création de vos présents